[Music]
joining me today is British author
journalist and political commentator
Douglas Murray he is also the associate
director of the Henry Jackson Society
and associate editor of The Spectator
Douglas welcome to the Rubin report very
good to be with him to see you in person
I don't know how we haven't done this in
person yeah I didn't haven't been
another it's yeah what in God's name are
you doing living anywhere else besides
LA well it's it's actually not my
favourite bit of America I have to say I
find it's slightly unscented and
rootless but it's also I don't drive so
la is sort of hell because you can't
walk anywhere but well I know you're not
making that up because you were stuck on
a plane for about 4 hours last night you
arrived at like 2:00 a.m. then we tried
to send a car to get you this morning
that took some time as long as if it's
me being difficult but now I actually
managed to watch the three films before
the plane even took off last night yes
New York anything good no-oh-oh ever I
don't watch many films they're all bad
yes always bad almost always bad do you
feel you're at your intellectual best
right now because you didn't get much
sleep are you ready to do this I depends
that rigor as you want to be yeah well
I've got some pretty rigorous questions
right here but I think that's an
interesting way to kick off because
you're somebody that you know everything
that I that I see you write and the
events that you speak at and the talks
that you give and all that stuff I mean
you have to be at your intellectual best
pretty much all the time I don't know if
you feel you always are but but what
kind of pressure does that put you under
just to be to be one of the people that
you know you have to have a cohesive set
of thoughts and be able to defend them
all the time I'm not sure you have to
have no um I tell you what I mean I
don't admire don't envy politicians for
having to have the thing of having to
turn up say their I think never be off
message and a less sort of thing I kind
of feel that you know I'm a writer I can
I can have bad days I can change my mind
on things I can nuance things
texture things or I can be garbled one
and you know nobody says oh my god he's
a total train wreck I don't know I don't
know if they did I wouldn't care but
well it's funny you say that cuz right
before we started we were talking about
social media a little bit you were
saying how you don't respond that often
or pay too much attention to that and
not on Facebook I'm on Twitter I use
Twitter as a way to communicate to the
few people who care you know anything I
write or appear on but I don't talk to
the world as it were I don't think it's
doable
I think it drives people mad I've seen
some of the least you know relatively
promising minds of my generation
slightly wrecked by social media
yeah you know you wouldn't you wouldn't
seek out people to shout at you on the
street so you wouldn't if they did say
come over here it's like your basis and
do it when I wake up and turnover in the
morning and tell my phone on yeah
so I do think that people have to find a
sort of reasonable way to live in this
strange strange world which is even
stranger than a hey obviously yeah well
it'sit's much stranger in LA and we are
going for dinner tonight I'm gonna show
you how weird it can get even think you
know what's weird in LA I'm gonna I'm
gonna really show you tonight tell me a
little bit so we've done this once
before and it was about two years ago
and I had just started doing an
interview show and we we talked about a
lot of the problems that we both had
with the left and the rise of Islam and
some of that we're gonna cover here but
I thought maybe we could just talk about
a little bit about your history first
and what kind of brought you to be one
of the one of the few people that is so
outspoken on some of these issues what
what made you care about the free speech
stuff about what's happening in the West
all of this stuff when did that really
spark in you um it's hard I mean these
things are easier to recognize in other
people than they are in yourself I've
written about a lot of different things
in my life I started writing very young
they became I became a published author
so I wrote my first book when I was 18
it came out and I was 19 or 20 I think
and that was on literature and I
literally figure and then I started
writing about politics and the one thing
which somebody once said to me about me
is it was I I thought
probably someone near the truth was
somebody once said that I had a very low
tolerance threshold for lies and I think
there is something in that ID I
genuinely maybe it will wear out at some
point but just over days as it were on
nice but right I just I find I don't
like being told lies and I don't like it
about historical think that's my first
books partly about it I think it's a set
of historical misunderstandings that it
happened in relation to the figure I was
writing about and I wanted to correct
them and then in politics of course if
you have a low tolerance threshold for
lies maybe it's just not the right yeah
that was made expression maybe you
picked an odd thing to be writing about
got into surfing or something I don't
know but yeah but but politic politics
and political lies you know galvanizes
me and i suppose the other thing is that
I'm not a political nut I'm not I don't
really care who's running in that
district for which part in which you
know party they voted for four years ago
and I sort of think is interesting it's
not what I spend my life feeling taking
pressed or you know enamored with but I
do I do think that if you care about the
culture in the widest sense as I do then
you've got to be interested in politics
you you you've got to take some attitude
towards it and they say not not in order
to you further your political goals or
something you want to do that it should
really be a politician but I think in
order to try to safeguard the coach I
mean I mean I don't even mean the coach
I mean really to safeguard the practice
of culture and that's what politics
seems to me to be very largely for and
I'm quite interested in taxation I'm not
very interested in it
I just want the circumstances to be
right for the culture to thrive yeah so
when people say oh you know I'm not a
political person or something like that
I hate that phrase because it really
what are you actually saying you look
like you're either pretending that
you're above it or you somehow don't
need it and yet politics you're right
it's about creating the conditions so
that you can do all of the other things
you care I think what people what a lot
of people mean when they say that is I'm
not a party person
I'm not going to bore on about the
Labour Party or concerta party or the
Democrats or the Republicans I think
that's what what people Amin but in any
case a lot of people who said that some
time ago don't say that anymore in fact
that maybe the more they said in the
past they weren't a politics person the
more now they're shrieking and gibbering
and storming yeah do you think there's a
danger in that so we had all these
people that you know whatever that
whatever that meant to them they weren't
politics people but now everybody's
shrieking and screaming and everyone's
in the part of it that you just said
that doesn't really do it for you that
piece of the day-to-day racehorse stuff
and that's why I try to focus on the
philosophical right because the the
who's running for this or all of that
stuff yes it's important at some level
but it's the bigger picture stuff that I
think really matters yes and you know to
a great extent in your country and in
mine there is a type of person now who I
think has got politics all the wrong way
around I mean maybe it is as I say
people who didn't pay much attention to
it in the past but there are people who
are now I think putting onto politics an
amount of weight that it can't bear yeah
it's about their entire existence as it
were and I wouldn't want that to be the
case at all
I mean I you know I had with a colleague
some time ago sort of informal
competition of the Conservative Party
won the 2015 election in Britain had an
informal competition to say you know
what's of nuttiest thing anyone said and
the best was it his woman at the
Guardian who wrote a column saying that
basically she cried herself to sleep
every night and she woke up in the
morning crying is she
sometimes she stalked him she woke up
and she thought oh my god I've had a
nightmare no it's true and then she
burst into tears again that person
shouldn't really be in the community
should they right but if I I mean I you
know I have views I was on who I want to
win and any one time which party I'd
vote for but but I cannot imagine any
scenario in which I became such a
gibbering wreck that I've just wept all
the time or because she might not have
been telling the truth is this Conor ray
or thought it wise to say to people
that's the state
right right right well it shows her
victimhood she's such a [ __ ] oh she
can't sleep the best is when you see the
Huffington Post or one of these pieces
probably in the Guardian to where it's
not just them that are crying their
children yeah waking up having
nightmares about your mom my
three-year-olds having a nightmare about
drumming mommy what I say what can i
what should I tell my three-year-old but
now he's asking about trauma again
I know it's time to go to sleep you know
it's so funny I I tweeted this out a
couple months ago but when within the
middle of the election you know all
these articles are being ready to kick
how trump is affecting kids this morning
so I asked I asked my my at the time I
think he was five or six my nephew I
said what do you what do you know about
Donald Trump he looks at me he's like he
has bad hair and a red tie that's what
again that's what a kid would think all
right so I want to talk about your book
but I thought before we get inside I
want to do a little bit more on just
sort of language in general and the free
speech thing so when you come to America
because we have some extra protections
for now at least on free speech that you
guys across Europe don't have do you
feel an extra degree of freedom you
don't strike me as someone that ever
bites your tongue but when you come here
and know that we have such a great free
or do you see something a little
different here that I think you do I
mean I I think you just got to separate
out between the what your legal rights
are as it were and what the actual
practice is these days
yes legally I mean there's nothing I say
that's illegal in Britain or Europe and
so I don't particularly feel freer to
say anything here exist nothing I would
say here that I wouldn't say there and
vice versa it's true that you're having
an amendment your constitution that
actually writes this in a law is a very
useful thing to have
we've course don't even have a
constitution in Britain which has its
own advantages and problems but but I
think these things have to be slightly
divorced in the reality of the practice
as is at the moment and at the moment I
think you're probably you know
worse situation than we are in Britain
or Europe in relation to speech mainly
because of a generation of people who
are growing up and the most privileged
generation in history who seemed to
think that speech is violence and that
in response to violence you should be
violent and if you make that leap then
the response to somebody speaking is to
hit them and oughta shuttin down want to
burn a building or to get them killed or
whatever you want and I see that all the
time all over the place some day I know
in Holland who there's a couple weeks
ago a lot of people in the press of him
demonizing him and then say his house
was attacked two nights ago and I'm
Saddam and there's lots of that going on
loads of loads of targets selection and
and I think I think all this is very
very worrying but I I do think that in
general you you seem in America to make
terrible generalization do we slightly
further down the road of certain manias
about this it seems to embedded itself
more this idea of being wounded or even
hurt by words and and yeah and you've
got all of the SJW stuff slightly worse
I think yeah it do you think that maybe
just that in and of itself could be just
a cultural thing that Americans kind of
scream about things more were hysterical
you guys are a little more polite I was
asking a friend in New York about this
the other day it's I wonder whether the
you know that thing you always hear in
America this is the most important
election of our lifetime every single
one yeah and it's always I mean by the
way I'm fascinated by the language
hyperventilation in this country and I
was fascinated by that moment before the
last election when Bill Maher said look
we called Senator McCain the misogynist
and we were just he doing it try to get
him and we we recognized he wasn't and
then we did it on him and then we were
as he wasn't really Romney wasn't really
misogynist but now this guy is so I'm
fascinated by this thing of basically a
lot of sort of chickens coming home to
roost in some ways you
kept running the language down and now
you're in this position but I said it's
friend America the other day maybe that
the V as it were the hyperventilation of
politics is one of the ways in which you
keep your democracy fresh I mean maybe
you have to live for that pitch I mean I
wouldn't particularly want to live at it
myself all the time but perhaps the kind
of this is always the most important
moment ever is important for this
democracy maybe it's better than the
sort of doesn't really matter or ya
never gonna be as good as that again
that's a really ruminate on that a
little bit cuz I think you can argue it
both ways I think I mean it's why you're
saying you can I can see a problem with
that level of hysteria all the time and
you're right when when Bill Maher said
that oh yeah yeah the left was saying
all these horrible things about McCain
we did it about McCain we did about
Romney this is the real one well you've
cried wolf to the point now that what
did he expect to happen in an odd way is
that is that a pro Trump argument
strangely like he was of course what was
gonna happen here
you know what I mean like you tried it
with you tried it with some decent sort
of center right people right but of
course you're gonna get this then right
maybe maybe I'm resistant myself to the
introducing Donald Trump will miss any
discussion after they almost always
derails after and after almost
everything that happens in the UK and
recent in the last year or so okay well
how will this affect Donald Trump just
stop talking about them to say allow
other things in the world to exist yeah
as well so you're saying when I think
your Mayor of London was saying we don't
want Trump to come here you'd be okay if
Trump showed up right
I think that's greatest thing but Donald
Trump has made an official visit to
Paris yeah he's made official visits to
Germany to a tourist so quite a lot of
Allied countries by now I think yeah I
think it's outrageous and I think people
should protest if they want to protest
but and I remember the protests against
George W Bush when he came to London and
during his presidency and there was
there some very very Vermont protests
but I don't my people for testing of
course
right I just I think this attempt to say
I mean our most important ally and
particularly an important time in our
national history in Britain we need to
be reforming our alliances and renewing
them to say eff off to the president of
your closest ally seems to me to be very
very unwise as well as as rude yeah is
it one of those things where it's just
it's it's just the easy answer you know
just out all that I'm here we'll it
shows how good we are don't let in here
but actually what you do you're actually
do damage to probably the most important
ya know a relationship that these
countries have salutely I mean when the
Mayor of London says we don't want him
in London yeah well well he's in Paris
he's in Berlin like what have you
achieved the best you will you'll damage
among other things the economic
relations between Britain and America so
nice work mr. mayor nice work
right right all right so we're almost
we're almost at your book so I thought
this is the good transition here I was
listening to I think it was you're not
your last discussion with sam Harris
maybe the one before that and you were
guys we're talking about language and
sort of the slow erosion of what's
happening in the West and the rise of
Islam a lot of the the key stuff that we
all kind of talked about and you were
talking about how we're gonna be arguing
about gender pronouns as all of our
rights are gonna be taken away from us
you said it far more eloquently and with
some better adjectives but I thought it
was a really interesting point that our
our eye is not on the prize no in that
we're not focusing on what's really
important worried about things that are
not to say trans gender rights aren't
important but they're they're not the
big pictures know how important is all
of that focusing on the right things I
think it's crucial I mean I'm people can
be interested in whatever they like but
I also have the right to time I think
they're wasting their lives gender
pronouns all this sort of thing these
this is there is by the way behind all
this something very strange I started to
notice there among all the fascinating
things about this one of the ones that
interests me most is why you get this
this introduction to almost every
discussion as if we as human beings are
sort of solvable things I find this
fascinating most of the trans stuff is
you know identify that you're of the
wrong gender at an early stage by the
way I'm very suspicious about all that
but I think can think of a lot of
effeminate young men who shouldn't have
drugs even encouraged towards them yeah
when you say that you mean you're
suspicious of the way we're treating
them or of the sort of psychological
sight because the the psychological
thing in general but let's say in the
case of somebody actually does genuinely
feel that they are in the wrong body and
so on that there is this awful thing in
it as in so many other discussions at
the moment of and if you Nix that you
you'll be on you'll be right mm-hmm and
I think no no no once you you sort that
out you'll face all the same problems
everyone else faces in their lives and
maybe some new ones but this this is I
hear this in the race discussion in
America I hear it in the gay discussion
in America in in a whole set of them
it's as if it's as if if we get the
formula right I think I I just think
this is a fascinating mistake I don't
think we live our lives as solved or
solvable beings and and we are we are
engaged it seems to me in particularly
in this society in America in this
strange attempt to sort of get it the my
new Shai right and apart from being
deeply navel-gazing okay it seems likely
to me that that we may be missing all
the really important things that are
going on I have this sort of haunting
view always that we all feel like we've
really sorted out every aspect of LGBTQI
rights just as China becomes the most
important power in the world very
interesting right an interesting yeah I
think it's a fascinating piece because I
was gonna ask I was going to talk a
little bit more about this at the
but you're gay and I asked you in our
last interview right at the end by that
fact alone how much does that give you
an extra sensitivity to all of the other
things that you're talking about you
have a vested interest you and I and I
think yeah all of us I think all humans
all together have a vested interest in
keeping the West or I sure but I think
as a gay person it's particularly
important that the last places of
tolerance and Western thought are kept
alive yes I have to say my in case
that's not particularly a galvanizing
thing I have to say I mean I think being
gay is kind of boring as a subject from
the way because certainly for my
generation I mean we sort of came out it
came out and by your twenties right who
wants to keep going on about that albeit
I understand of white people did before
but you know you there's not a career or
life as it were and just being a gay you
know I mean it's not a full-time
occupation so many of us can be in
reality TV there's only so many fashion
gigs on Bravo and I so I've never I've
never picked and it's never particularly
influenced my politics and in fact I may
have said to you before I'm generally
very opposed to the idea of politics
being about what am I myself and how can
I get the world to most accommodate
itself towards me mm-hmm
I think it's certainly mistake having
politics should be search for some kind
of truth or the best arrangement that
allows the truth to occur and you know
your own involvement in it or your own
comfort in it is of importance but it I
mean I wouldn't want somebody said I'm
totally into this because I'm fighting
for myself and that's it in fact whether
we're sorry since you mention it on some
of this stuff on the Islam sufferance
it's actually the first warning sound to
me was not dreamed of gays I was dreamed
of Jews which I became sort of
increasingly noticing there was a
problem a couple of decades ago now but
um it was that I'm sure how how are you
sir - in Britishness well I was I was
worried about it because I started to
notice that there were things that were
being said that I thought wouldn't come
round again and I say I'm not Jewish
myself that you can
notice these things and and not need to
as it were have a personal vested
interest in in it you know and I mean I
suppose one other thing I said is I I
generally think I mean the atomization
of society into groups with their own
interests is one of the things that's
causing that all this mess in America at
the moment I don't see why the job of
gays should be just to sort of fight for
the gays and the job of the Jews should
be to fight for the Jews and and so on
and so forth I think I think the idea of
sort of looking out for each other is
surely the point in a republic and yet
that point seems to be lost right so is
that where this this intersectional crew
has really lost it because they said
they're sort of getting what you're
saying that we should be looking out for
each other that should bring all of
these minority groups together except
instead of that they're vying for me
depressed the vine fights oppressed and
most ridiculous and most
hyperventilating and all of that but the
intersectionality people I mean there's
two big things one is they are the prime
culprits of this thing of the myth of
solvability the myth of humans our
ability right if we just if we get the
Rubik's Cube right and okay the games
get there then we get the trans in and
then there's people here and the
non-binary love this and and then the
Muslims get there and we could all think
exactly they can all think exactly the
same and speak in exactly the
preferential order that without speaking
it will all be fine with my view is
you'll still have every single problem
of the world ahead of you you'll still
have to work out where your foreign
policy is a whole load of stuff is
coming but so that's that's the first
thing but the second thing is they are
obviously breaking apart American
society I don't think that's too much of
an exaggeration because they started at
the universities and it's trickling
across everything else and I've been
having really interesting conversations
with people about this in recent years
in Europe as well as in America and one
of the things I'm sort of slightly
confident about here in America is that
you do have an answer to it and it's an
answer you've had before you know the
problem of the identity politics thing
is we're already starting to see that
apart from being wrong in itself and I
think more
suspicious and selfish you can't stop
what you're gonna create on it you can't
have racial rights for every group and
racial pride rights every group and
always hold back white you know pride
whatever mm-hmm you just you just can't
at some point is gonna break
you can't keep bashing heterosexual men
and not expect at some point that
there's gonna be some kind of response
so if everyone's allowed their group
apart from the majority or whatever then
at some point that's gonna get nasty and
I can see it coming
so clearly yeah I mean we see it now and
it's already started and the thing is
that in America you had the answer to
this which is what Tocqueville mentions
it's it's that the deal of being in the
Republic is you don't do that you you
deal with each other face face to face
as citizens you don't you don't do it as
just people coming to hawk something in
the marketplace but face to face as
individual citizens in the Republic and
this this is the only way out but I
think they'll obviously be some mania
before you get back there again yeah you
know it's funny you get that may you get
back a week yeah versus I may you know
it's funny the way I do the show I try
not to talk about individual people too
much because I'd always rather focus on
the ideas but as you're saying this I'm
thinking of something very specifically
that Linda Sarsour who I'm sure you're
know I spent an evening with in this
also in Brooklyn really yeah yeah that
go before a I tell you I think we got on
roaring Lee I said some man you guys I
know how to write was a bit of sexual
tension in the room unavoidable but no
the the fact is actually she and we're
asked to debate the croc fandom word
Islamophobia at the Brooklyn Art Museum
and I like a challenge and I think our
mutual friend ayaan Hirsi Ali was also
meant to be there but I think that
various things happened the garland
shooting happened and it was decided it
wasn't safe yarn I still did it and
things but yeah the whole thing that he
started off with the other side sort of
giggling about the fact that I saw ray
arm we couldn't even turn up you know it
was really using it against her and as
if I Anne's afraid of anybody
yeah and and yeah and I and I said yes I
think countenance I saw before she
became as it were infamous and I thought
she was a very nasty very bitter very
unamerican actually I just say that
because she she knows like all
demagogues how to introduce herself and
introduce herself to some proud Brockton
I to proud American a proud Palestinian
except Osetra know and I thought in an
interesting order but it was clear that
she sort of really hated America or at
least hates America that exists
currently because I was me that ended up
having to explain to the audience that
for instance the New York police don't
just go around persecuting Muslims you
know it's just a willful
misrepresentation of of the American
authorities at every turn so I thought
she was very dishonest very unpleasant
and but I mean I've come across her type
all my life yeah and the only reason I
mention her is because of what you said
previously which really was about
assimilation that the whole point of
America is to assimilate and I don't
know if you saw that speech she gave
about two months ago where she called
for a ji-hye and suddenly the left was
defending the word jihad and the white
supremacist in the in the White House
and all that but I thought the key part
of it put jihad aside put white
supremacy aside the key part was when
she said we're not here to assimilate
yes I thought what a that is the
antithesis of the American project this
amazing melting pot that we have where
we've done for the most part
multicultural right multiculturalism
right where Europe has failed in a lot
of ways and she was saying no no
absolutely and I thought that was more
dangerous than the others absolutely of
course I mean me as you said I mean put
aside I know the fantastical idea that
what she was suggesting was you know you
sort of have a a jihad by kind of going
and just really in a struggling in front
of it you know I I'm just struggling in
front of this Israeli
I'm having a turmoil yeah that yeah this
is this is what I recognized the night
we met I mean she really doesn't like
this country by the way I mean we all
have a problem by that what you what you
do about that
mmm it seems to me she's a sort of very
rabid sectarian sort of Palestinian
nationalist who happens to live in
Brooklyn but I mean really what you do
about it is that people identified that
recognizes and called out for what it
was what it is and they just aren't
there many people who do that still I
mean that you know we all take sort of
baby steps on this don't we know as you
saying now you end up with the left
sword offending Welsh even problem in
this and I thought you just said look
she's not speaking as a critic of our
society who wants to sort of mildly
improve it she's speaking as an opponent
of our society because she doesn't like
it mm-hmm
I've encountered this I say all my life
in my opponents and the very close
enemies I've made in Britain and across
Europe a certain type of person of that
ilk who clearly speaks as an opponent of
the society they don't like it and of
course among other things all you can do
is point to point out then is to say you
know amazing your hair really isn't it
amazing yeah and that's the catch-22 of
what we've got in the West right we're
gonna have to let in all sorts of voices
that's that's the beauty of this thing
and it also creates a little bit of the
bread all right let's talk about your
book first off I love the title the
strange death of Europe I thought using
the adjective strange was particularly
interesting why did you choose the word
strange not slow or a series of other
things that you could have used the
first is it's an odd which not many
readers will get to a slightly known
history textbook or the strange death of
liberal england which described the
decline of the Liberal Party in the
early part of the 20th century but
that's their sort of isn't needed it was
know it although there was a slight
similarity yes a really little thing is
it is just it is odd I mean it's it's a
curious way to go
and I think if you'd have said to anyone
of one or two generations ago that this
would be what Europe's issues would be
in the 21st century that basically it
couldn't couldn't find any way not to
just allow the world to walk in and join
them that those generations would have
been surprised and so yes it is it is
strange it's and I but I try to explain
why and I and in order to explain it I
try to explain it from not just from the
you know the sort of first-hand accounts
and the statistics and all that sort of
thing but but the deeper philosophical
reasons why this is happening I think
that's you know so lots of books do bits
of that but I want to just say look this
is the whole overall picture this is
this is what we're actually living
through and this is why yeah so the
subtitle is immigration identity and
Islam does that order have any meaning
to you in the way you phrase those
particularly I mean it centers on the
2015 migration crisis when Angela Merkel
opened the doors of Europe and couldn't
really find a way to shut them again but
they'd already been open for a long time
as I explained though I mean it's these
these are the three massive things that
that are preoccupying I think not just
Europe but Europeans at the moment the
immigration crisis where the public's of
Europe just wanted to stop all across
the continent all the polls all show the
same thing the public wanted to slow
down or stop so that's the immigration
bit of it the identity bit of it is the
very very painful thing which you know
people aren't very good at talking about
maybe I'm not very good at talking about
it but I think it's just there
underlying everything what is this thing
what is it to be a European who who can
be European can anyone be and is Europe
home for the peoples who've been in
Europe or is it the home for anyone in
the world who wants to move in and call
it home he's a very very big question
yeah these are bad and then
third one of that is the Islam bid which
I mentioned because it's obviously the
sharpest bit of this ah you can have
somebody move in I know you can have a
Nigerian Christian move into a bit of
the South of England and they will have
issues they bring as everyone does they
will have their own ideas as everyone
does their own culture they've walked in
from and everyone does but it would be
the person of another background for
another community in another faith who
would be coming in with the issues that
are really starting to nor it Europe we
we find this very hard to talk about and
it's getting easier very very slowly but
you know our big worry is we've not been
great on the integration all of our
leaders say this all the European
politicians admit this now but the bit
that is is wiring us is Islam bit
because I think there's now a general
awareness that maybe this is a bit we
can't digest or we're finding it
unusually difficult to digest and
incorporate I don't say it's impossible
by the way I just think for all sorts of
reasons it's proving very hard in May in
the years ahead proved far worse so I
know that you often make the distinction
like most educated people you make the
distinction between Islam as a set of
ideas as any religion is simply a set of
ideas versus Muslim as as people in this
case do you think that there is
something unique I mean this is always
what triggers my friends on the left if
you say that there is something unique
about the set of ideas of Islam that is
different than the set of ideas if we
just take the big three monotheistic
ones that is different than the set of
ideas of Judaism Christianity or at
least how their practice I think is the
more operative part because you can look
through all the books and there's plenty
of bad stuff in the Old Testament do you
at the end of this do you believe that
it's just incompatible that this set of
ideas is incompatible with the set of
ideas that the West is trying to
preserve I think I think
reformed Islam presents a very
significant values challenge and it's
probably not reconcilable if if we have
as it were the Islam of most Muslim
countries its it's very hard to see how
that's doable I think all of this is
very painful isn't it because first of
all we live in any case in an age of
relativism already where for perfectly
good reasons sometimes you know we sort
of pretend it's all sort of the same you
know I might be a Muslim you know you
might be a Christian she does yoga and
it all comes out in the wash
right now it's the same and I just think
that's to begin with that's obviously
not true I mean it's very strange to to
want to concentrate on everything other
than the premises and origins of a
belief structure hmm
and as I've often said stop me if I've
said this to you before but I mean you
know there are all sorts of problems in
the Christian religion and in Christian
history but as I've often said you know
what just carry out the thought
experiment that instead of getting up at
Sermon on the Mount and saying you know
love thy neighbor and you know and
forgive people endlessly Jesus have said
if your brother offends you chop his
head off would Christianity's history
have been more bloody or less bloody I
think we all agree it's gonna be more
right well I'm buying the Jew behind the
tree yeah yeah if Jesus didn't say that
but if Jesus had gone into the whole
like fine you know the Jew behind the
tree and slaughter him yet have whatever
the context right then there would be
even more a Christian anti-semitism
mm-hm and then there has been
historically so I just think these
things matter and I all this is very
very painful for a reason that I go into
in some depth in the book which is that
in recent years we in countries like
Britain I think in America have had the
luxury of sort of describing ourselves
in terms that among other things have
been universal but what we have should
also be universal now this is a very big
this is always a debate within
liberalism of course is liberalism
something we have or something we as it
were expound and and and expand
and in recent years I think that a
certain moroseness has landed across
Europe among other things because of a
growing awareness maybe what we have is
very unusual and that we have become
disassociated from the roots in which
what we enjoy grew and this this is a
problem there's a German legal theorist
I quote in the book who puts this is you
know one of the central conundrums for
Europe is it possible is it possible
that the thing we're enjoying and living
through can survive without the
connection to its roots and I believe
that the roots of the West and of Europe
in particular fairly clear and it's a
combination of things it's the
inheritance from ancient Greece and
ancient Rome it's obviously the
inheritance of the Christian
civilization that washed through that
throughout the continent and then the
refining fire of the Enlightenment and
skepticism and all these things and of
course we go and endlessly about the
other things that have added to it but
broadly speaking that is what made
Europe Europe and what made a European a
European they breathe this this air but
but but they're sort of the last man at
the end of that which I fear modern
Europeans are is is in this strange
position of finding it hard to even
identify where he and she has come from
let alone being able to return to those
roots and nurture them because we all
have I have I'm sure you have a
conflicted set of views about this you
know is it necessary for other people to
believe those of us who had who have
sometimes been tempted to hope that for
instance skepticism is enough yeah
constantly depressed by the discovery
that for instance somebody may be a free
thinker about God and that's it
rethinking point of view yeah from then
on it's tribe all the way and you know
we're all we're all living through this
but it's for Europe I think that the
combination of the historically
unprecedented
two people in four continent at the same
time that this sort of breakdown of what
we are ourselves is going on is a is
their fatal fatal thing so there's a lot
there that I want to hit but I what you
said right at the beginning which is
that if Islam if unreformed or not
allowed to reform so I think that's
particularly interesting for the space
that you and I sort of exist in because
I have many allies who are reformers I'm
not just I allies that are X Muslim I
have allies that are Muslim and keep
many many people that I've interviewed
that you know but they're treated harm
horribly and they're and every time
they're allowed to get a platform or
it's actually by the evil conservatives
yes people right yeah or all the things
that people who don't like me you'll say
about me or show about you or any of
that stuff that makes the job a good
Julian time well order I say in the book
towards them when I try to rouse myself
to some prognostications about all this
that this is the worst possible sign not
just that the people that we might talk
about in these terms are so few and that
between us you and I might have them in
our phone books not just that but who
are the ones that are most Thunder under
pressure and under risk they really are
the they're the good guys to say that
this is a tragedy for Islam is obvious
but it's always been my view that we
should try to avoid making ourselves a
casualty of Islam's civil internal
strife and I think we haven't done that
I think we've spent recent decades
almost deliberately running towards a
fight that didn't need to involve us
mmm-hmm so that the tragedy of Islam
becomes the tragedy of the West as well
I hope this could be avoided but I think
it can't and I think that as I say the
worst possible sign for the future is
that it's you know hammered apple salad
in Germany who lives under protection
let's imagine nowise who comes in for
the grief in the UK it's a young Hirsi
Ali who followed the Dutch integration I
deal more than anyone yeah who ends up
having to leave Holland yeah these are
very very bad signs you know you can
still live
you know Hamas military commander in
London nice fine
yeah you'll be celebrated in some ways
right I mean this is a huge problem all
right so let's let's knock out each one
of these words we've sort of hit that I
think a bit of each one already on the
immigration front when you said that
Merkel or just open the doors I see a
lot of different stuff written about her
that she either intentionally you know
you get sort of the conspiracy people
that she wanted to destroy Europe or she
hates her own country and all this stuff
I try not to impugn everyone's motives
but when this happened in 2015 and there
was this combination of refugees and
immigrants and migrants and nobody could
figure out what was happening and we saw
videos of people just thousands of
people just running across borders and
all this stuff and an odd amount of them
that seemed to be men in their 20s and
not women and children and all that
which implies that they're often
migrants looking for work well even use
earn figures the frontex figure said the
majority of the people who came in 2015
have no right to be in Europe which is
which is fascinating and somehow even if
you say that you'll be labeled whatever
but what do you think her intention was
in 2015 well I this is why I try to go
back to the beginning not just with
history but also with the philosophy on
this
I don't impute you know terrible motives
to her I think that she was blackmailed
by history was facing a truly terrible
humanitarian crisis which was
undoubtedly going on and I stare this in
the face and I travel around and speak
to many many migrants from all over the
world have been to many of the countries
they've fled from but I also go to speak
to them in the countries that they
arrived into and speak them in the camps
and certainly have met and listened to
more migrants and I think any of my
critics but you know it's it's it's it's
easy to exaggerate the ease of the
situation that she faced or the ease of
the solution to it and and I think I
shouldn't be done it was a genuine
crisis it remains a genuine crisis and
the biggest imaginable moral question so
we also know that at the moment that she
made the decision in 2015 to basically
suspend all border controls
I suggested in my book but since it my
book come out has come out it's already
now being confirmed by somebody was with
or at the time that what happened in
particular was that somebody said to
Merkel we cannot have German border
guards repelling migrants and the photos
go around the world right so this is
just condemned because of history
it's what yes it's what one French
philosopher calls the second career of
Adolf Hitler mm-hmm it's an ugly way of
looking at it but it's it's it's not
entirely impossible mm-hmm this is this
is just this is another go around this
terrible terrible history and past but
you know it's not conspiracy I show in
the book how much it's more what we call
in England cock-up I've always tended
towards the [ __ ] out view of history
because if you see politics up close as
I have done quite a bit throughout my
life you know that it's not really
people pursuing grand sort of schemes
really it's people who haven't done the
job before because you can't and there
is no qualification that gets you in
position beforehand and trying to deal
with not long-term things but tomorrow
morning's headlines and you know media
action the next day and they maybe they
drown below the the surface of this
babble yes that's how politics happens
these days right which is not the way
that both sides talk about politics they
wanted they want to make it seem like
the other side has constantly this grand
plan and everything's going according to
the Han or as I say in the book the
every single thing we thought would
happen didn't happen and nothing that
has happened was expected I go back to
the 50s you know the guest workers who
were the first people who came in after
the war well first migrant waves into
Europe from Turkey and elsewhere
it was Merkel herself said in 2010 we
expected them to go home I think
credible markup yeah but then we
expected and then it didn't of course
they they wanted having tasted first
world you know economics and among other
things they wanted to bring their
families and of course and if you have
your family
enter the schooling system and you'll
need health care and then you'll need
that as an element especially if the
state's giving you a lot yeah this thing
and and that's why we are we are we're
where we are we're we're you know the
2011 census identified people who call
themselves white British on the census
as a minority in London minority in 23
out of 33 London boroughs it's why all
the demographic projections from across
the continent show Europeans I think not
to overstated losing the place they had
to call home or at least becoming a
minority in it and this you know there
are some people who talk about that and
in the sort of language of haha and the
Empire Strikes Back now you're getting a
taste of it you went round the world and
now the world's come to you and among
other things I warn those people just be
careful of that language the language of
punishment because if the language of
that is as it were the punishment for
colonialism then down the road you'll
create a movement it'll say well we
managed to end colonialism yeah and then
they'll come for you too no matter no
matter what you do so with that being
said so the identity part then is
obviously inextricably linked to this
when you see the this sort of what seems
to be the rising white identitarian
movement or European identitarian
movement or or whatever what do you what
do you make of it do you view it purely
as the natural reaction to this is there
anything legitimate out of that it are
there parts that are not racist or is it
truly based in racism I'm very very
worried about this the moment I have to
say very very worried if you have people
saying I'm proud of the color of my skin
because it's a skin colour of course
there will be some people who'll do the
opposite I am somebody said to me the
other day other than questions are you
proud of being white and I said no of
course not why would I be proud of a
pigmentation but I didn't turn around
and said no but I'm if you ask me if I'm
proud of my culture I'd say of course
mmm-hmm but it's something else than
that I am it's not really about pride in
the Carter III
some years ago I wrote a piece about
this for book the Prime Minister Gordon
Brown was editing on Britishness I said
I I don't think of these things in terms
of patriotism I think of it in terms of
gratitude I feel gratitude before I've
been lucky enough to be born into I'd
love it if other people who wanted to be
part of it became a part of it and I
think they can and I think it shouldn't
be and can't be racially exclusionary I
mean it's madness hmm
but it's a madness it seems to me that
some people will be falling into by
being pushed and by being ignorant and
other things but you know I come back to
this thing there will be some people who
will and I've found this a lot in
conversations across the continent in
the last year or two there will be
people who will grab a bit of the
identity thing for themselves for
tactical reasons we will get to this
goal and we'll use a dishonest tactic
just like you're using it yeah and there
will be other people who will say no
it's not just a tactic is what it's what
I feel it's what I believe I just
strongly urge people not to go down that
route strongly urge them not to go down
the route of identifying by an accident
of skin pigmentation but to say if you
if you want to talk in terms of values
and in terms of civilization and of
culture you cannot make it exclusionary
like that but the point about this is
it's that that can't only be that it's
the as it were white young guy who's
told that right you've also got to tell
it to the angry young black demagogue
who's telling people of their own skin
colour to isolate and congregate around
around race it's good he's got
everyone's got to you know make the deal
as it were on this yeah but I just am
filled with with you know concern about
this and that probably has a little
something to do with the word strange
because it seems to me that it's
possible
that the ship has already sailed on this
perhaps more in Europe than in America
because you guys had an integration
problem already which is finally being
acknowledged now but then you also have
this new set of people so even if
everything was fantastic with all the
people that were there and all the
integration before 2015 what do you even
do with just the new set of problems let
me give an example by the way the in
Scotland there's it's a small amount now
but a Catholic Protestant mainly
centered around football supporting
Celtic Rangers we they go by religious
affiliation ok still yes still yeah
that's because of a movement of
Catholics from Ireland into Scotland a
long time ago yeah let me give you
another example I had a very dear friend
who died recently who was a brilliant
very very brave man called Shona
Callaghan who was a double agent within
the IRA my other trouble than he he got
up to the top of the IRA command and he
was informing all the time to the Irish
state and saved many many lives he's an
extraordinary extraordinary man I wrote
an obituary for him and others of his
friends did one of the most negative in
fact one of the only negative pieces of
our short was in The Boston Globe who
referred to him as a as a as a grass as
somebody who after you've come out and
written his memoirs became to hawk them
around America not not just selling
among Hawking a book mmm-hmm why would
that appear in the Boston Globe
only because a very long time ago a
large number of people from Ireland
arrived in this country and settled in
Boston and held on to their Irish
identity and some of them held on to a
belief that the IRA a murderous
murderous sectarian gang were as it were
their people so all these centuries
later the attitude in the boston globe
when a man who risked his life just and
save many many other people's lives dies
he's to attack him basically as a grass
anderson
okay that's the movement of Catholic
Irish people into America
who on earth thinks that when you bring
the entire developing world into Europe
including very very large numbers of
young men from the Muslim world that
this is going to be sorted out by next
February yeah you know or you know
roughly this time next year so does this
show you know I use the phrase lazy
thinking all right but maybe that's not
the right way it shows an inability to
think you know what you said about
Merkel in 2010 it's like well we thought
they were gonna leave that's not lazy
thinking that's man did you even think I
mean you know it's pretty good in
Germany you know if you let people in
is there ever been a self-imposed a
group of people that left a Western
country to go back to it - sighs very
uncommon yeah of course once people once
people you know realize that the
economics works better Europe does in in
sub-saharan Africa of course of course
they come but we I mean we're just so
torn about this and I I think we have to
rouse ourselves to more than moroseness
we're talking about it it seems to me
because we're not sure why or yeah I'm
pretty sure why but as coaches we're not
entirely sure why it should be our right
to keep anyone out I'm not here this
obviously in America now America has a
different issue of course it's America
it is it's legitimate to say America is
a nation of immigrants yeah it's not
legitimate to say that about Britain it
just isn't hasn't been till the late
20th century a nation of immigrants me
very very static population even the
Norman Conquest the thousand years ago
shift in the population by about 5% in
the UK so um you know I understand that
in America the whole thing to do with
immigration is a bit harder people feel
they're talking not about them but about
you or me and in Europe that that is a
bit of the case now there are people
talking those days but there's also
there's also just this additional thing
of by what right by what right would I
be allowed to say anyone can't
now I think there are all sorts of ways
you argue it I mean I the law should
matter right the law should matter the
difference between legal and illegal is
everything yeah look I'm not a Canadian
why is that because we have a border
right and that means that a Canadian has
to obey the laws of Canada yeah and I
have to obey the laws of the United
States people think that even and of
itself that somehow controversially by
the way what a beautiful thing it has
been watching Justin Trudeau have to
face it's so easy for politicians in
Europe we've seen a lot you've seen it
here in America Canadians have seen it
it's so easy to grandstand on this let
them in open the doors because when the
effects happen hopefully you'll be out
of power and you'll be retired somewhere
in a nice area with lots of people like
you which was your dirty little secret
all along he'll move to New Zealand
isn't that where they're all moving New
Zealand that is money that's fun but but
the Trudeau's on he was operated and
morally grandstanding and then of course
when this movement of people from
America across the Canadian border they
start getting bill gates by the way at
the beginning of a migrant crisis said
that America should take in the same
proportion of migrants that year as
Germany did Germany took in an extra 2%
of its population in one year alone and
Bill Gates in we should taking the same
numbers in in Germany in it as Germany
did in Britain America well interesting
enough only a couple of months ago Bill
Gates did a reverse ferret on that
actually no he said he said 'no said
remarks that if germany continues like
this it's it's going to destroy it well
imagine if Bill Gates instead of being
the world's richest man had been in
charge of anything mm-hmm
then you'd have gone through what
Germany is going through and it would
have vastly outlasted him as this will
outlast Merkel and all of us so the
issue it seems to me the two things that
I can point out one is demanding that
our political leaders in particular
think through things beyond the two-year
electoral cycle or the four-year
electoral cycle or more importantly just
tomorrow in the morning
headlines like you might have a bad
morning's news it's a lot better than
[ __ ] up your country it's a lot
better it really is and the second thing
about this is we have to develop the
ability to have an adult discussion
about these things that recognizes it's
not between you know your for the
migrants I'm against them or you know
your Churchill I'm Hitler your
Chamberlain your Hitler just to have the
discussion on recognizing these are
different opinions about our future and
and that you know I say toward the end
of the book that we have the tools for
doing this Aristotle showed us a long
time ago this is just a competition
between virtues Angela Merkel very
understandably felt the human virtue of
mercy to be merciful towards people who
are trying to come and I say yes but
there is another virtue competing with
that which is a virtue of justice not
just justice for the people of the world
wanting to come and have a better life
but justice for the peoples of Europe if
you have the discussion on those terms
between competing virtues not doing good
and evil right and wrong
Churchill Hitler me good you Nazi then
you might be able to get somewhere in
this discussion but it's as if we've
sort of wounded ourselves before even
starting at the start line yeah
so as to people that try to engage in
that I think that's what we consistently
try to do and I see you debating all
sorts of people from every walk all
right yeah i have a promiscuous debating
yeah you've debated basically everybody
anyone yeah i some people at you know
now in prison not because i had debated
and so much they were process you never
I mean you know I've debated lots of
people who I'm sure you've sent a couple
of people to mental institutions after
they've had to deal with your wit never
ed it's not that I mean I definitely if
if somebody is is out in the general
public and has a platform and and they
wanted to pay I always have the view yes
yeah that's not sale debate anyone by
the way sometimes people get oh yeah oh
you wouldn't debate me I think
you've got two Twitter followers yeah
and you're nuts yeah you're a blue fox
on Twitter yeah you're like Xena Warrior
Princess nineteen no nothing everybody
kill that woman really wants to debate
all right I think I think we got a nice
holistic piece of this here so I want to
just shift altogether to end this on a
on a something somewhat unliving
uplifting as someone that that does all
this that you speak about this stuff you
deeply care about this stuff I you know
I worry about this stuff constantly
people I'll be staring off into nothing
in the middle of the day and I'm
literally worried about the fate of the
Western world you know I I wish I was
playing video games again as much as I
used to but yeah you know me that much
well I lost you on the video game thing
yeah but what do you do for fun what do
you do to just forget all this stuff and
just enjoy yourself and be human oh gosh
I
well I know you don't like this type of
question because this is well I'm rather
careful about as it were private matters
I am very happily in a relationship of
many years I love my family I've got
wonderful friends I see them a lot I to
relax I read I read all the time not
just it's enjoyable but because it's
just just endlessly learning and
thinking and so it's just so stimulating
sometimes when you have that thing of
what I described is catching up with a
truth you'd always known was there
mm-hmm
the thrill of recognition that you get
from reading that I think is harder to
find in video games or television all
right so you know I do a lot of reading
as I'll shift this a little then so what
would you say more importantly than that
to the to the person that's watching
this the the type of email that I get
all the time the person that is just a
regular person you know working a
regular job that sees these problems
that here's you that is not a bigot and
is not a racist but is genuinely afraid
of doing what you do every day which is
say what you think that they're
genuinely afraid of just putting their
thoughts out there be it on social media
or be
it's getting to the point where they're
afraid to talk to their own spouses
about what could you say to somebody to
give them a little bit of a boost and I
tell you what that the the waters not as
cold as people say it really isn't
I mean it's it's hard this one isn't it
because if you there has been a lot of
focus on the negatives certainly and
some of the things we were talking about
today in recent years and there's a sort
of growing feeling unless you want to
pre-visit recent interviewees a Google
guy is a demonstration the more that
stuff happens the more that people keep
down and it's very hard to I mean you
can't be brave for other people
you can't tell other people you know
speak up mm-hmm but I think we can
encourage each other to I mean um you
know sometimes people approach me in a
sort of you know I house my friends I go
to concerts I read things I want I enjoy
the music I love and and I travel where
I like I go all over the world and we're
not gonna need any extra security
tonight are we I hey we're going to
Beverly Hills I think we'll probably
down lens we've pick a fight with
anybody but no I am I mean it's you know
there's a sort of exaggerated yeah well
that's it that's why I'm asking you this
question cuz I do think it's partly in
people's mind you starts being and then
you realize yeah I know you know
somebody said some bad stuff about me
but yeah they'll hear yeah exactly so
people some quite a lot of the time
young journalists and thinks enemy I'd
really like to write this but I don't
dare and all this sort of thing and you
know I'll get this look just just to see
and just write it and I mean no one ever
rewarded somebody for a career in
journalism the way they said nothing
over there are some writers at New York
Times you could you could say but you
know you just just dissed dude and if if
it doesn't I'm very lucky in that I've
spent my career saying what I think and
being able to earn a living
precariously but successfully
and I feel like I can write for when
we're sending the newspapers I want to
write for and almost all of them will
have me and I love writing for a range
of them now I've very lucky to do this
but it's not like it's not like that's
rare I mean I mean it's it's still legal
to say what you think and and I so I I
just hate it when people say like really
my you for saying what you're thinking
what the hell do you do and but it's
only it's only that we all we all get
used to the idea and just just sort of
just one other thing which is just also
I think about you but I find myself more
and more tolerant of people's opinions
just more and more tolerant of it I mean
I see but I see people driving
themselves mad yeah and I just sort of
think I mean there are some things I
have somebody you know they do I
discover they're into you know Kitty
fiddling or something and I'd have
something to say to them but pretty much
you know on politics and all sorts of
things I find myself like oh that's
interesting why do you think that mm-hmm
and and you know it's fascinating and
who would want to keep all that down and
you know as long as we agree on the
parameters as long as we agree that you
know we don't shoot and stab each other
which is obviously up for negotiation it
seems at the moment but as long as we
don't do that venom I what's the problem
just just speak don't expect somebody
else to do it for you I don't don't
don't siphon it off like some wing of
government like the free speech Center
it's for you to do thrust to do so
everyone that's a end an interview
Douglas Murray is on the Twitter he is I
have just been informed via the
teleprompter you're a thousand followers
away from a hundred thousand is that
right no you're monitoring this
constantly yeah and you must have these
which I think we can get you there
should I do something like if I get
100,000 followers I'll do something what
would you do I don't know
risa discusses well this guy's it over
drinks all right for more on Doug let's
follow him on the Twitter he doesn't
care that much but I want the man to get
to a hundred thousand its Douglas came
Ari thanks
you